warm yourself up and get ready for a
chilling holiday tale because it's time
for a new episode of Sabrina and this
one's full of holiday cheer part one of
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina left
us with makeover Sabrina freshly signing
the book of the Beast and on rocky
ground with her boy-toy Harvey kinkle
this special Christmas edition of
Sabrina looks to festively bridge the
gap between parts 1 & 2 and sets up
right after the events of the finale at
the end of this video I'll get into what
some of this might mean for part 2
coming out this April but first how many
of you were naughty this year and
skipped the intro missing this new image
of Santa going towards the North Star
it's also important to note that the
North Star was used by the three wise
men on their journey to meet Jesus when
he was born and who shows up at the end
of this episode three demonic wise men
but let's go back in time to find young
Sabrina well cast here with McKenna
Grace who you might recognize from the
haunting of Hill House and I Tanya she
looks pretty to him close to Kiernan
Shipka set some time in yesteryear hilda
and mr. Putnam have taken Sabrina and
Susie to see jolly old Saint Nick at the
local mall Hall somewhere
they also casually chat about kids in
Greendale getting abducted Susie asks
for a truck for Christmas while Sabrina
just wants to see your mommy looks like
this is the year Sabrina learned Santa
isn't real
flash-forward to the week before
Christmas or as the witches call it
winter solstice and the Spellman's have
set up a nice Christmas wreath featuring
a satanic pentagram Sabrina admires a
photo from her favorite Christmas memory
that time she looks super sad and asked
Santa to bring her mom back the spellman
celebrate the winter solstice in
Yuletide winter solstice marks the
shortest day of the year in Yuletide is
a pagan festival celebrating the Wild
Hunt and faustus's secret daughter baby
Leticia is here too at the end of part 1
we left Ambrose amongst a crowd of
faustus's fanboys looks like with him
here and knowing about the baby he's
still on Team Spellman Zelda announces
it's time to light the Yule Log a piece
of magical firewood that will ward off
the spirits of winter solstice who
intend to cause mischief on the longest
night of the year upstairs Sabrina
confines in Ambrose that she's
conflicted about how to handle being a
witch with mortal friends and she wishes
she could ask her mother's advice
she also revealed she saw her mom in
limbo you'll remember in part one
Sabrina ran into her mother while trying
to save Tommy kinkle from limbo and in
my ending explained video I speculated
that must mean Diana Spellman has some
unfinished business so Sabrina comes up
with the idea to communicate with her
mom through a seance after all winter
solstice is when the veil between the
living and the Dead is at its thinnest
thus the need for extra protective
measures like the EULA but Ambrose
doesn't seem too keen on the idea of
messing with the dead so what does
Sabrina do every time her family says
not to do something she heads to miss
ward well aka Madame Satan
looks like Wardwell is getting the cold
shoulder from the Dark Lord now that a
new younger model has signed the book of
a beast typical naturally when Sabrina
asks for a book of the dead to help with
her seance Ward will hands it right over
then the moment Sabrina leaves she
begins to monologue to our poor stuff
stolen that she mustn't let Sabrina
learn about her mother's past
Sabrina Susie and Roz if they'd like to
come along for her Mommy and Me time but
the two of got plans Susie's gonna be
working as a Christmas elf helping Santa
in walks Harvey and Sabrina and him go
off to have their first chat since
breaking up looks like Harvey's dad is
taken to the bottle and Sabrina tries to
patch things by giving Harvey some
magical crayons at the academy of the
unseen arts Sabrina asks the weird
sisters for their help with the seance
and they agree because there are orphans
and have nowhere to go for the holidays
Roz visits Susie at her elf job and you
can notice this strange dated a tire of
the mortals in Greendale all throughout
the series we've seen a melding of time
period fashions that continues here this
scene in particular feels like a
throwback to a Christmas story but with
more creepy mannequins out kid as Roz
leave she gets a flash from her cunning
ability something's not right here and
I'm not talking about Susie's dream of
being an elf after Susie shift she's
helping out with the important task of
wiping down the mannequins which seems
weird until you realize these things
freakin cry turns out Santa is evil and
he's been turning his assistants into
wax mannequins and Susie's up next why I
hate it when this happens
meanwhile Wardwell has a new delicious
version of voodoo for the Spellman's
this
it's Gingerbread she even changed
Serena's hair to white Wardwell pours
water down the ginger Spellman House
chimney and causes the Yule Log to go
out leaving the house vulnerable in
Sabrina's room the seance begins and
Sabrina's mom appears but before we can
learn anything that might give us a clue
as to why she's in limbo other ghostly
spirits and to the house causing zelda
to rush into the room and interrupt cut
to December 21st winter solstice the
shortest day of the year
Sabrina's concocted an eggnog remedy for
alcoholism she plans to give to mr.
kinkle but mr. King Cole won't drink it
until one question is answered what a
gem speaking of great moments and being
a dad mr. Putnam goes to check in on
Susie the morning after her shift
apparently he didn't notice she never
came home from work Susie's too busy
being locked up in Santa's creepy doll
house we get a good look at who mr.
Bartell really is here later on in the
episode they will reference him as a
demon named Bartel which is another name
for what we commonly know as Krampus for
those of you who don't know Krampus is
the anti Santa who instead of rewarding
children during Christmas takes them
away in a sack
or in this case turns them into wax
check out the goat like horns a typical
feature of Krampus fact the Spellman's
Ambrose takes a break from some holiday
embalming when he gets a surprise attack
from the ghost of the corpse before
hearing the sound of children laughing
Hilda - as an experienced that cuts it
close and Zelda finds the children of
stolen Leticia away and placed her in
the warming oven which personally seems
like a bad place for a baby to be but
that's just me apparently the house is
being haunted by the Yule Lads who enter
the unprotected houses of witches on
winter solstice and can only be wrangled
by their mother growl aah - somewhat up
growl as a witch who's pissed because
she offered her kid as a food during a
famine but once the meal was over none
of the other witches offered to serve up
their own kid in return which is
downright rude and what's with all these
witches in eating each other anyways now
she's obsessed with anything related to
children and so she collects them and
turns them into Yule kids
kryla comes in and apparently has spent
the last thousand years applying
eyeshadow Zelda and Hilda doll for some
lovely pastries in exchange for
wrangling her spirits but all growl is
really here for is the ginn let's get
the party started
where's dad meanwhile Ambrose hits up
Luke's Christmas party that's apparently
for warlocks only no girls allowed as
growley gets a sufficient amount of gin
and goes to leave she hears Letitia cry
out when Sabrina drops her pacifier
since Grail is all baby crazy she
changes course and won't take her you'll
boys till she gets the child as kryla
and Zelda have a Mexican standoff over
the baby the spirit of Dianna Spellman
appears wearing the crown of Saint Lucy
who is most commonly known for the
celebration of st. Lucy's Day a feast
that marks the lighting of the first
Christ candle around Christmastime Diana
also mentions being brought both by
mortal and infernal spirits the demon
Lucy being the infernal this theme of
duality good and evil night and light is
a constant in the show and continues
here but most importantly mama Spellman
has a suggestion on how to settle the
matter baby tug of war this game of baby
pulling is also very similar to the
judgment of Solomon in which King
Solomon of Israel ruled between two
women both claiming to be the mother of
a child
Solomon revealed their true feelings in
relationship to the child by suggesting
to cut the baby in two and just like the
true mother in the story Zelda breaks
away rather losing the child than
risking hurting her so guerrilla heads
back to the mountains child in hand but
of course this is another scheme set up
by Sabrina the child was a fake an
enchanted teddy bear to fool the witch
there's a knock at the door and it's Roz
frantic that Susie's gone missing she
fills Sabrina and the Spellman's in on
her cunning vision of mr. Bartell as a
demon which Hilda confirms Zelda then
tracks him down using the magic of the
mortal phonebook and the gang zooms off
to save an elf
just as Bartel is about to add Susie to
his version of Madame Tussauds rila
shows up she's been tipped off by the
Spellman's that someone's been missing
with children and that really grinds her
gears Susie escapes and Bartel gets a
taste of his own wax medicine as kryla
turns him into Lumiere after the wild
events of the solstice Zelda decides it
would be safe to leave Leticia with this
Melda you'll remember his Melda as the
Witch of the woods from the feast of
feasts episode Sabrina gets one final
visit from her mother who recommends
Sabrina not lead her mortal friends down
the path of the night along with her
before vanishing into the wind Harvey
comes around to inform Sabrina that the
eggnog worked but to stop magic fixing
his life he doesn't trust it after
she you know turned his brother into his
zombie and basically forced him to shoot
his bro in the head
Sabrina returns to a nice family
solstice by the fire and Oh Luke is
there look at him even when he's
supposed to be nice he just seemed so
evil evil I say
Sabrina gives us one of these Satan
bless us everyone god bless us everyone
and Ambrose reads A Christmas Carol
all the while three demons emerge from
the kinkle mind to leave the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina on an ominous note
until April so where does this leave us
for part two first of all the three wise
demons at the end the big clue for the
next part is ICEA these three heavily
mirror the three wise men in the story
of the birth of Jesus Christ
the wise men being the ones who
prophesize Christ's coming
three wise demons could mean the coming
of the opposite the Antichrist perhaps
right in time for season two we can also
expect Roz and Susie to be in a lot more
magical danger this upcoming season just
like Susie was here now that they know
Sabrina's a witch there's nothing
stopping them from stepping in some deep
which leave Oh doo doo doo Sabrina and
Harvey Aras will they won't they as ever
Harvey's not willing to forget
everything Sabrina did at the end of
part 1 but he's also not willing to
completely sever his connection with her
and you know Nick is gonna try to get on
this too will Zelda actually go through
giving away Leticia
something tells me after that tug of war
with growl ah it's not gonna be that
easy for her and if they were able to
contact Diana Spellman what's stopping
them from being able to do the same with
Edward will Salem ever speak will Luke
ever reveal he's pure evil that's it for
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina a mid
Winter's Tale if you enjoyed this video
be sure to like subscribe and share it
it's gonna be a few more months until
Sabrina comes back but until then I'll
still be breaking down tons of great
shows and movies so be sure to stay
tuned until April keep walking that path
of night and remember daddy loves you
very much